countries have a central bank the Puppet
Master of the economy the bank of all
banks for that country the central bank
which we call the FED here in the U.S is
run by the government so their job is to
set the rules or policies that all the
other banks have to follow and the
Central Bank isn't motivated by profit
but rather their job is to babysit the
economy to keep it growing to make sure
people have jobs to make sure that
prices don't fluctuate too much so that
we can keep growing nicely no slowdown
no recession that is what the FED is
there for they pull strings in the
economy to get us to spend our money in
a certain way which in turn affects how
much businesses raise or drop their
prices and guess what it totally works
one of the strings that they have to
pull in the economy is called the
interest rate want to borrow money to
buy a car or a house or expand your
business you're going to be way more
likely to do that if you only have to
pay two percent interest on that loan as
opposed to like six percent lower
interest rates equal people and
businesses want to borrow and spend
money we're like freaking puppets